saying there's a there should be a
separate set of standards for cheating
for men and women not great that's not
going to go over well with a lot of
respectable women no no don't tolerate
that it's not going to go over well but
it doesn't mean that it's not true why
do you feel that's true that there
should be a separate set of standards
for you i don't think that there should
be no but i think that there is but
people right but that's different you're
saying what you're saying is different
you're saying the reality is that
in society maybe it's more accepted for
men yeah but it's more accepted for
biological reasons so like people will
claim like society is just against
female sexuality but then they fail to
realize the biological reasons for why
that may be and that's why i don't like
the feminist argument especially when it
comes to sexual promiscuity for women
because
this the reason why societies were
against sexual promiscuity in every
culture all across the entire world
because there are natural there are
biological concerns when it comes to
giving birth that's been a dangerous
thing for forever that's a natural
concern for women forever that's been a
dangerous thing when it comes to stds
syphilis wiped out hundreds of millions
of people throughout ancient throughout
history so when you talk about uh so
when it comes to women being promiscuous
that's a very dangerous thing for
culture that maybe they're not
suppressing it because they hate female
sexuality maybe they're suppressing it
because they don't want to die you know
what i'm saying so like people will just
go female sexuality has always been
suppressed but then failed to realize
the natural reasons why it was
suppressed and it's because it comes
with a lot of consequence especially for
women a huge one is paternity if you're
sleeping with everybody in the village
how am i supposed to know this kid is
mine so nobody's going to raise it and
you're probably going to be left a life
of
selling yourself trying to make ends
meet so there were there were societal
pressures for women to not do those
things because of the natural
consequences of it so a lot of the
societal pressure comes from natural
consequences now fast forward to now we
have the birth control pill that takes a
lot of that effect away we have uh
penicillin for diseases like syphilis we
have better treatment for diseases that
takes a lot of that away but we haven't
gotten to the
the point that there's an emotional
difference an emotional attachment that
comes with women just sleeping with
multiple men and the stat the studies
show
that the more promiscuous a woman is
before marriage the less happy she will
be in that marriage and the shorter that
marriage will be on average so when it
comes to a man
putting
uh essentially gambling 50 gambling with
50 of his current wealth and potential
wealth
if i'm a male's rights advocate i can't
talk about shoulds i have to talk about
what is their reality now and their
reality now is women are sexually
liberated that's fine but that means as
a man if you want to look at things
if you want to go about things the best
way to get the best results
taking a risk of marriage it marriages
is more risky than ever for men because
of that fact see the reality to me
though is that everyone seems unhappy i
don't everyone seems unhappy no one
trusts each other i think that men cheat
i think women cheat i cover on the show
a lot of stuff about women behaving
badly sloppy drunk at the club sleeping
around i wasn't raised that way that's
not how i lived my life i i you know i
was taught to respect myself respect my
body i think that's the way women should
behave but i also feel like that's the
way men should behave i feel like the
message out there should be to everyone
at this point like
you have to level up when it comes to
this stuff respect your body respect
yourself get into a relationship where
trust and fidelity matter understand why
that has value even if you have a
different instinct maybe you're talking
about biologically maybe men have
different instincts when it comes to i
don't know if this is like a spread the
seed topic or yeah that's
and i really didn't even point on the
fact why it's different like cheating
specifically that was just female
promiscuity in general right but
cheating specifically when it comes to
men and women it's it is different it it
is just different right but the
inclination is different than acting on
that inclination and what you do in a
relationship right yes so so like what i
say is what i i personally believe that
men are here to build and maintain
societies and compete to spread their
seed into the next generation i think
that women's contribution mostly to
society is to
be selective with who they pick to
spread the seed into the next generation
so women have to be more selective and
the truth of the matter is you can't get
promiscuous men without promiscuous
women that's right every culture has
understood that that's right so you
that's why there are social consequences
for women being promiscuous and the
reason why you implement social
consequences on women because we see
women as weaker every punishment for a
man is is capital you go to jail you get
killed you blah blah blah for women is
social you say don't be uh this this or
that because people are gonna not like
you and because women tend to be social
beings that's a huge punishment for them
like for a daughter you don't have to
whoop her like you might have son or do
whatever or the punishment doesn't have
to be as harsh because if you just say
that you're disappointed in your
daughter especially from a man going to
his daughter that's going to be enough
to have her in tears that's going to
make that's going to be enough to for
her to understand
that
what she's doing has consequences so you
know it's just it's just different if
you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]